Le Népal n'est plus le paradis des
randonneurs et des touristes,
en mal de grands espaces.
Le royaume est le théâtre
d'une guerre civile ignorée,
mais pourtant sans merci.
Au pays natal de Bouddha,
aujourd'hui, on égorge.
Le roi Gyanendra,
héritier de la dynastie des Shah,
affronte des rebelles maoïstes fanatiques.
15 000 combattants
qui n'ont qu'un seul objectif,
renverser la monarchie !
Si le roi n'accepte pas nos conditions,
il faut qu'il parte.
23 millions de Népalais sont pris en otage
entre l'armée et les rebelles.
Les maoïstes nous disent de ne pas
aider ces chiens du gouvernement.
Au milieu de la tourmente et malgré les
menaces, un Français, Jean-Louis CHABASSUD,
tente d'aider la population népalaise.
Ils sont en train de gêner
le gouvernement par tous les moyens.
De gêner les villageois
par tous les moyens.
Il accepte de me guider
au pied de l'Himalaya.
En plein cœur du conflit.
Katmandou, un nom mythique
qui fait toujours rêver.
Une destination initiatique
pour des milliers de jeunes,
et pour des alpinistes
en quête d'exploits.
Aujourd'hui, la capitale du Népal
est désertée par les touristes.
La ville est sous haute surveillance.
L'armée patrouille 24h/24 pour tenter
de déjouer les attentats maoïstes.
Jean-louis a débarqué
au Népal il y a 15 ans.
À l'époque,
il était photographe professionnel.
Face au dénuement de la population,
il a décidé d'aider les plus pauvres.
À présent, il parle népalais
et il connaît tout le monde,
même les sādhu, les gardiens
mendiants des temples hindouistes.
Jean-louis a ouvert
une agence de randonnée.
Avec les bénéfices, il a bâti un
dispensaire et une école dans la montagne.
Ce matin, nous l'accompagnons
à son dispensaire.
La route est longue.
7h et le trajet dangereux.
Les maoïstes sont partout dans le pays.
Mais ces malades ont besoin de nous.
On augmente énormément
le nombre de patients,
parce que tous les dispensaires de
la région ont complètement disparu.
Soit ils ont été explosés, soit ils
ont été fermés par manque de moyens.
Pas de contrôle de l'armée,
pas de barrages maoïstes.
Les premières heures
se passent sans encombre.
Où nous en sommes ?
On est à mi chemin du dispensaire.
Il n'y a que du goudron, maintenant,
on prend des chemins de terre.
au bout 1h30 de route, on se
retrouvera en zone de non droit.
On se retrouvera dans une zone
qui est ni maoïste totalement,
ni gouvernementale.
Une zone de non-droit où les maoïstes
peuvent attaquer à n'importe quel moment.
Ces maoïstes tiennent la moitié du pays
grâce à des actions spontanées.
Voilà, ils tiennent la moitié du pays
par des petites actions de commando.
C'est toujours un petit peu sanglant,
surtout quand ils cherchent quelqu'un.
Quelqu'un qui à moucharder, ils n'hésitent,
ils l'attrapent n'importe où,
et ils lui coupent la gorge.
Ils n'ont pas tellement de munitions,
donc c'est plutôt les gorges.
Dans les villages, la misère est partout.
Au Népal, plus de 50% de la population
vit au dessous du seuil de pauvreté.
L'espérance de vie ne dépasse pas 58 ans.
Un terreau favorable pour les maoïstes
qui recrutent,
jusque dans les hameaux les plus reculés.
Dans les villages, comme celui-ci,
il y a des maoïste ?
Il y en a automatiquement.
Ils sont là-haut, derrière,
qui viennent le soir, qui repartent.
Des rebelles qui agissent
par petits groupes très mobiles.
Difficile pour l'armée de combattre
un ennemi aussi insaisissable.
Il arrive que l'armée puisse
arriver à l'improviste ?
Oui, mais l'armée
est à un heure, même pas.
Ils patrouillent le long de la route ?
Oui, on risque de voir des patrouilles.
Là bas, ils ont un poste très important.
Arrivé à ce poste, tout le monde descend.
Les bus sont systématiquement arrêtés
et les passagers fouillés.
Gare à ceux qui essaient
de sortir du rang.
Ici, tout le monde s'exécute.
Chacun peut être suspecté
d'être maoïste,
et les arrestations arbitraires
ne manquent pas.
Les maoïstes cachent des explosifs dans
les coffres à l'insu des conducteurs,
et des contrôleurs d'autobus.
Ils essaient de tromper notre vigilance.
Parfois ils viennent sans armes,
et c'est quand par hasard, on trouve des
documents dans leur sac qu'on les démasque.
On peut alors les arrêter.
Cette fois, pas de suspect.
Nous pouvons reprendre
notre route jusqu'au dispensaire.
Encore 2h si tout va bien.
Un barrage de la guérilla maoïste
est toujours à craindre.
Dans le bus,
les passagers sont silencieux.
Terminus de la ligne.
C'est ici que Jean-Louis a construit
son dispensaire il y a une dizaine d'années.
Voilà, on est arrivés au village.
Ici, Jean-Louis est un homme respecté.
Tout le monde le connaît.
On l'appelle Chacha.
Mon oncle, en népalais.
Et quand il vient dans son village,
Chacha ne manque jamais
de saluer cette jeune femme.
C'est une infirmière d'un dispensaire
qui était à 1h de chez nous,
et qui a été fermé par les maoïstes.
Donc elle est là, elle vend des médicaments
alors que c'est excellente infirmière,
et excellente gynéco.
Est-ce que tu crois qu'elle nous parlerait ?
Non, rien que là, elle vient de me dire
"on se reverra pour parler".
Le dispensaire est à l'écart du village.
En dépit du calme apparent,
les rebelles ne sont pas loin.
Les traces de leur présence sont partout.
C'est la route qui se termine là, au bout.
En attendant qu'une autre soit construite.
Mais les travaux sont arrêtés
depuis à peu près un an au moins,
et ils rançonnent les entreprises,
et donc les entreprises
s'arrêtent petit à petit.
Un racket systématique.
Les pelles mécaniques ont été brûlées.
L'entreprise avait refusé
de payer l'impôt révolutionnaire.
Pendant le blocus, ils avaient mis
des affiches disant :
"Il ne faut pas bouger, restez chez vous."
Les gens obéissent ?
C'est obligé, si vous en tuer 1 ou 2,
il n'y a plus personne qui bouge !
En fin de journée, Jean-Louis
arrive à son dispensaire.
Voilà notre royaume.
Donc j'ai une chambre à Katmandou
et un grand royaume ici.
Aujourd'hui,
ils ont soigné sur 70 personnes.
Chaque année, plus de 20 000 malades
viennent se faire soigner ici.
Nous avons beaucoup de problèmes pulmonaires
et il y a beaucoup de brûlures aussi.
Brûlures, c'est suivant les saisons.
C'est maintenant que ça va commencer,
parce que les gens restent assis autour
d'un réchaud qui est gonflé avec pression,
et qui explose de temps en temps.
Les enfants surtout qui sont au
premier plan, qui sont brûlés.
En plus de son dispensaire,
Jean-Louis a ouvert une école primaire.
Trois classes qui accueille
220 enfants de 5 à 9 ans.
C'est l'association de Jean-Louis
qui finance cette école,
gratuite pour tous les élèves.
Finalement vous appliquez le
programme maoïste.
Je ne sais pas si c'est être maoïste,
mais l'école gratuite, l'hôpital gratuit,
mais nous on a commencé il y a
bien longtemps, il y a 12 ans,
alors qu'eux ont commencé
il y a que 6 ans,
On a peut être été maoïste avant eux.
Les enfants sont parfois témoins de
la guerre qui se déroule autour d'eux.
Près de l'école, ils ont abattu un garçon,
18, 20 ans à peu près, qu'ils considéraient
comme voleur ou quelque chose comme ça.
Ils nous ont obligé à laisser le corps
devant l'école pendant 3 jours,
et toute la population
a dû défiler devant.
Les écoliers aussi.
Mais où sont donc
ces rebelles maoïstes ?
Pour parvenir jusqu'à eux,
je vais changer de guide.
J'ai rendez-vous le lendemain avec Matrika,
un journaliste népalais arrêté
plusieurs fois par la police.
Les autorités le soupçonne d'être
proche des révolutionnaires.
Matrika a accepté de me conduire
dans son village perdu dans la montagne,
en pleine zone rebelle.
Direction plein est.
En chemin,
des carcasses de voitures calcinées.
Lorsque la guérilla décide
le blocus de la capitale,
personne n'a le droit de rouler.
Le mois dernier, les maoïstes
ont décrété 2 jours de grève,
mais certains ont
quand même voulu circuler.
Ils leur ont demandé de descendre
de cet autobus et ils l'ont brûlé.
À Charikot, l'atmosphère devient tendue.
J'aperçois des hommes bizarrement vêtue.
Visiblement fatigués d'avoir marché longtemps
dans les collines qui entourent la ville.
Pourquoi ces hommes sont-ils en civil ?
Lorsque les militaires sont en patrouille,
ils évitent désormais
de porter la tenue de combat.
Ils opèrent en civils,
habillés comme des Mao.
Dans les villages,
ils demandent aux habitants :
"Où sont nos amis ?"
Nous sommes maoïstes.
Nous venons de tel endroit
et notre commandant,
nous a ordonné de rencontrer
nos camarades.
Au sommet d'un col, l'armée a installé un
barrage où elle contrôle tous les voyageurs.
Dans ce poste, les soldats sont même
retranché derrière des sacs de sable.
J'essaie de me faire passer pour
un touriste, mais je n'y échappe pas.
Je dois sortir mon passeport.
Écrivez votre nom.
Je m'exécute. Dans ce fortin, les militaires
sont nerveux et la caméra est indésirable.
Toi ! Pas d'images !
Maintenant, nous sommes à Jiri.
Après Jiri, nous devrons marcher.
Mais c'est la dernière base de l'armée ?
Oui, c'est le dernier poste
de l'armée royale du Népal.
Après il n'y en a plus
et commence la zone maoïste.
6h du matin, le soleil se lève sur le toit
du monde, tout proche de nous.
Jiri est le point de départ
des randonnées pour l'Himalaya.
Avec nos porteurs et notre guide,
personne ne prête attention à nous.
Qui pourrait se douter
que le but de notre expédition,
n'est pas d'approcher les neiges
éternelles, mais la guérilla ?
Pour y arriver, un seul moyen.
Le tracteur et sa remorque.
Un bon moyen de gagner
presque une journée.
La piste s'arrête plus loin.
Et aucun véhicule ne passe.
Grâce au tracteur, on peut avancer
au moins à 4 km/h,
Donc plus vite qu'un homme à pied.
Surtout qu'on est très chargé.
Nous allons traverser la rivière,
et après nous marcherons à travers la forêt.
Les ponts comme les routes sont rares,
les Népalais se déplacent à pied.
C'est un handicap pour l'armée,
mais un avantage pour les rebelles
en perpétuel mouvement,
et capable de marcher 10h par jour
en portant 50 kilos.
A partir d'ici, toute autorité a disparu.
La région est sous la coupe
des groupes armés.
Cette inscription est un slogan maoïste.
On peut lire que pour rendre plus
forte la République du Népal,
Le marxisme, le léninisme et le maoïsme,
doivent avoir une longue vie.
Mon allure est trop lente. Matrika veut
arriver chez lui avant la nuit.
Nous décidons de continuer à cheval.
Au Népal, ils sont rares,
leur valeur est inestimable.
Un paysan accepte
de me louer le sien,
mais pas question pour lui
de se séparer de sa monture.
Il nous accompagne et il tient
lui même la bride,
pour guider son cheval
dans les rochers.
Enfin, nous touchons au but.
Là, tu vois la maison
avec le drapeau rouge ?
Le fils du patron,
il travaille dans le militaire
pour le gouvernement.
C'est pour ça que les maoïstes
ont capturé cette maison,
et ils ont dit à la famille
de quitter le village.
Nous pénétrons avec précaution dans le
hameau. A première vue, personne.
Les maoïstes inspirent
une telle crainte,
qu'il leur suffit de planter
un drapeau rouge sur un toit,
pour que les habitants obéissent.
Les rebelles ne sont pas loin.
Mais Matrika, lui, n'a pas peur.
Il est ici, chez lui.
Notre arrivée n'est pas passée inaperçue.
Je suis persuadée que les rebelles
sont déjà informés,
qu'un étranger est arrivé au village.
À la nuit tombée, Matrika réapparaît.
Il n'est pas seul.
Il revient avec le commissaire
politique du secteur,
un des chefs maoïstes les plus
importants de la région.
Il s'appelle Budy Podle.
Comme beaucoup de cadres du mouvement,
il était auparavant instituteur et communiste,
avant de rejoindre le maquis.
Sa tête est mise à prix, mais il sait
que dans ce village, il est en sécurité.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez imposer
avec le maoïsme au Népal ?
Notre but est d'arriver au communisme, mais
nous savons que ce n'est pas possible,
dans l'immédiat au Népal.
Nous voulons que le pays
soit d'abord gouverné,
non pas selon des lois
édictées par le roi,
mais par une constitution
écrite par le peuple.
Les maoïstes traitaient le roi de chien.
Est-ce que lui aussi dans les réunions,
à la population,
il parle de la même manière ?
Oui, car le roi affiche
lui aussi ce type d'attitude.
Dans les villages,
beaucoup de gens n'ont rien à manger,
tandis que les revenus du roi
augmentent de plus en plus.
Ce roi est un ancien industriel,
c'est aussi un trafiquant.
Sans compter qu'il a reçu
l'héritage de son frère défunt.
Mais ça ne lui suffit pas.
Il en veut toujours plus.
Qui fait la justice ? C'est lui ?
Nous jugeons les gens
dans les tribunaux populaires.
Est-ce que le tribunal populaire
a déjà prononcé la peine de mort,
contre des collaborateurs du gouvernement ?
Bien sûr.
Mais nous tuons seulement ceux
qui sont contre notre guerre.
Si quelqu'un alerte l'armée
de la présence des maoïstes,
si quelqu'un nous espionne,
on l'exécute.
Comment procédez-vous ?
Comment on les exécute ? Nous avons eu
un cas très récent, pas loin d'ici.
Mes amis maoïstes avaient arrêté un espion.
Ils lui ont tranché la gorge
avec un poignard.
Lorsqu'il s'agit d'espions,
il n'y a pas de pitié.
L'entretien est terminé.
Budy Podle repart se cacher.
Interdiction de le suivre.
Le chef rebelle est prudent.
Il sait que la nuit,
l'armée patrouille dans les montagnes.
Ce soir, le sous lieutenant
Bantahoua est en mission.
Avec sa sectio, il traque les groupes armés.
Dans les villages, la population assiste,
effrayée, à ces incursions nocturnes.
Ce soir, les rebelles
ne sont pas au rendez-vous.
La patrouille prend le chemin du retour.
Livrer bataille contre un autre
pays est très facile.
Lorsqu'on se bat contre des terroristes,
c'est très dur de trouver la bonne tactique.
Nous menons une guerre difficile.
Une guerre difficile, comme le montrent
ces images tournées par l'armée népalaise.
Plus de 10 000 morts en neuf ans,
une guerre sans pitié ni témoins
sur les contreforts de l'Himalaya.
Les soldats déterrent les corps de leurs
ennemis pour les exhiber comme des trophées.
Malgré les risques, les maoïstes n'hésitent
pas à organiser de grands rassemblements.
Comme le montrent ces images filmées par
Matrika, le journaliste népalais,
en septembre dernier.
3500 rebelles se sont réunis
dans le district.
Sur ce document exceptionnel, les rebelles
apparaissent au grand jour,
et à visage découvert.
Au XXIᵉ siècle, il y a toujours
l'impérialisme américain,
qui, en tant que puissance mondiale,
détruit les êtres humains.
Mais la population du monde entier,
en regardant vers le Népal,
en regardant vers nos montagnes,
sont en train de se dire qu'un monde
heureux est en passe de naître,
grâce à notre présence sous la
direction victorieuse du Parti maoïste,
et du Commandement suprême
de l'Armée du peuple.
Ce jour là, ils ont organisé une
démonstration de force.
Les maoïstes ont divisé le pays
en trois régions militaires,
et ils sont capables d'aligner
15 000 hommes en armes sur le terrain.
Les femmes participent aux combats.
Ce sont elles, dit-on, les plus farouches.
Soudain, un hélicoptère de l'armée
vient jouer les trouble fête.
Dans la vallée voisine, un groupe de
combattants regarde le spectacle,
offert par la section de propagande.
Les femmes sont chargées de chanter
la gloire de la révolution en marche.
Pourquoi j'ai suivi les maoïstes ?
Un de mes grands frère
est tombé en martyr,
et j'ai pensé que je pouvais venger
son sang en adhérant au parti.
J'ai été intégré dans la brigade culturelle.
J'ai 19 ans.
Sita n'est pas la plus jeune.
Les enfants soldats sont nombreux
dans les groupes armés.
30% ont moins de 18 ans.
Le parti a annoncé qu'il comptait
lever une brigade de 50 000 adolescents.
Retour à Katmandou.
Je me rends dans un orphelinat
où sont recueillis,
quelques uns de ces ex enfants soldats,
qui ont réussi à échapper
à l'emprise des maoïstes.
Aujourd'hui, les bénévoles
de l'association Chandrodaya,
essaient de leur donner un peu de chaleur.
Sur les murs, des photographies
d'enfants disparus.
Les éducateurs en reçoivent des dizaines.
Chez les rebelles, les petits kidnappés
ont subi un véritable lavage de cerveau.
C'est qui tous ces enfants ?
Des enfants qui ont eu
des problèmes avec les maoïstes.
Seulement avec des maoïstes ?
Qu'est-ce qui t'es arrivé, toi ?
Les maoïstes m'ont emmener de force.
Je ne voulais pas les suivre,
mais ils m'ont traîné par les bras.
Mes parents pleuraient.
Les maos m'ont obligé à marcher
très longtemps dans la forêt.
Qui l'ont amené
avec eux dans la forêt ?
Ils m'ont obligé à transporter une
grosse boule, très très grosse.
C'était une bombe.
C'était très lourd.
J'avais beaucoup de mal à la porter.
En fait, il portait des munitions ?
Ils portaient ça dans toute la montagne.
Et ensuite, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
On a mangé, eux,
ils ont fait une sieste.
Et dans la nuit,
on est descendu jusqu'à un village.
Ils ont frappé à la porte d'une échoppe.
Le commerçant est sorti
et ils l'ont braqué avec un fusil,
en lui mettant une main sur la bouche.
Ils lui ont volé son argent
et ils l'ont tué.
Ils l'ont tué devant lui ?
Oui, j'ai beaucoup crié.
Ils m'ont mis la main devant la bouche,
comme avec le commerçant,
lorsqu'ils lui ont tranché la gorge.
17h, l'heure du repas du soir.
Au milieu de ces nouveaux amis, Krishna a
l'impression d'appartenir à une famille.
À l'orphelinat, il mange à sa faim.
Reste ses cauchemars
qui le hantent chaque nuit.
Aujourd'hui c'est Tika.
Une fête sacrée que tout
le monde respecte au Népal.
Jean-louis est revenu spécialement
à Katmandou pour bénir ses employés.
La Tika, c'est le jour
le plus important au Népal,
où les parents donnent
la bénédiction aux plus jeunes.
Et à cette occasion donc, on fait un vœu,
pour que dans l'année, de l'argent arrive.
Un peu plus loin
et malgré la menace maoïste,
des milliers de personnes attendent
devant les grilles du palais.
En ce grand jour, tous ceux qui
le désirent peuvent approcher le roi.
La Cour d'honneur est ouverte
exceptionnellement au public.
Beaucoup sont venus de très loin pour
demander la bénédiction,
de Sa Majesté Gyanendra.
- Vous attendez depuis longtemps ?
- Depuis 2h.
Seulement 2h ?
Oui, d'autres attendent depuis 4h.
Le roi Gyanendra apparaît
enfin devant ses sujets.
Le protocole est très strict.
Même les rayons du soleil
ne doivent pas incommoder Sa Majesté.
À ses côtés, les deux piliers
du régime, le ministre de l'Intérieur,
et le chef d'état major de l'armée.
Militaires et policiers sont les premiers
à se présenter devant leur souverain,
que les plus dévots considèrent
comme une divinité.
Derrière suivent les plus humbles,
les paralytiques qui espèrent remarcher
un jour grâce à l'onction royale.
Arrivent ensuite les Sadou mendiants.
Je suis moi même invité à m'incliner,
devant celui que les maoïstes
veulent abattre.
Dans une salle à part, c'est la reine
qui donne la bénédiction aux femmes.
Pensez-vous que tous les
Népalais aiment le roi ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Chacun d'eux aime le roi.
J'ai pourtant lu dans les journaux
qu'il y a des problèmes dans le pays.
Ça, c'est autre chose. C'est différent.
C'est un problème politique.
Vous savez, le Népal a été bâti par les rois,
c'est pourquoi nous les aimons.
Tout le monde ici aime la monarchie.
Vous voulez la monarchie ?
Oui.
- Vous ne voulez pas en changer ?
- Non ! Jamais !
- Jamais ?
- On adore notre roi.
Un soutien sans faille des partisans
du roi qui s'inclinent,
devant l'oriflamme pourpre
de la dynastie des Shah.
A l'inverse, des rebelles maoïstes,
qui rêvent d'abattre la monarchie
en pénétrant un jour,
armes à la main dans le palais interdit.